[Music]
imagine
you're out for a blissful swim trying to
catch a glimpse of some
beautiful whales the sun is shining
the water feels refreshing and oh
something just brushed past your leg
something slimy slithery
something really really
big a giant squid has decided
you're its next meal how did
a giant squid get the drop on you
are you going to be next on the dinner
menu
and how can your measly two arms
take on eight this
is what if and here's what would happen
if you were attacked by a giant squid
giant squids are one of the ocean's most
enduring mysteries
they live in the deepest waters of the
ocean and
are rarely seen by humans in fact
most of the stuff we do know about them
is from
dead carcasses that wash onto shore
like its smaller relatives the giant
squid
has two eyes a beak eight arms
two feeding tentacles and a siphon
all stuff you don't want swimming up
against you
giant squids mostly eat deep water
fishes and
other squids including going full-on
hannibal lecter and eating their own
kind
and they do not mess around in fact
they're known to attack
entire schools of fish from below
once they grab a meal with the suckers
on their feeding tentacles
they drag the prey down to their sharp
beak
this cuts the prey into more manageable
pieces
and as if you weren't already too scared
to ever go swimming again
they start doing even more damage the
giant squid then
uses its radula which is like a tongue
covered with teeth
this slices and dices the prey up into
even tinier bite-sized pieces dinner is
served
maybe you should get out of the water
like right now
if you're unlucky enough to be hunted by
a giant squid
i've got some bad news for you the giant
squid's sheer
size strength speed and hunting
abilities
would make it extremely difficult to
escape
the first stealthy move it would make is
attacking you from below
ooh horrifying right well it gets worse
the giant squid probably isn't going to
devour you right then and there
it's going to drag you into deep water
where it feels safe from its own
predators
because it's so fast you would
definitely struggle with the changing
pressure
and your eardrums would certainly burst
this speedy whiplash may also break some
of your bones
from the giant squid holding you so
tight
if you're somehow not dead by being
gripped and scraped by the feeding
tentacles
the giant squid would use all of its
arms to bring you
to its beak if you're at this stage
the hope of escape is pretty
non-existent
the giant squid is using all of its
strength to
pull you in for dinner and i know it's a
bad time to say this but it
won't be a quick death you see giant
squids
have a bit of a gag reflex problem so
they're going to eat you
nice and slow this is it
you close your eyes and prepare to be
squid food
wait what's that sound ah yeah
your buddy the sperm whale has come to
the rescue
now giant squids don't have much in the
way of predators but
sperm whales yeah they stay away from
those guys
researchers have found giant squid beaks
in the stomachs of sperm whales
and battle wounds from giant suckers on
their bodies
this means that your new best friend has
a taste for super-sized calamari
the giant squid isn't going down without
a fight though and
will go toe-to-toe with the sperm whale
now i know it would be super cool to
watch but
i think you're forgetting something
you're still underwater
if by some miracle you make it back to
land in one piece
you're gonna have quite the story to
tell it's a shame no one will
ever believe you this is because giant
squid sightings
let alone attacks are so rare
we still have so much to learn about
them there could be
millions of them lurking in the deep
waters and we wouldn't even know
and well beyond them there could be tons
of other creatures
lurking in unexplored parts of the ocean
the good news is
it can't get any worse than a giant
squid
right oh jeez i'm really gonna stop
jinxing myself
what if the kraken was real well
that's a story for another
what if
[Music]